when I was young I didn't really notice
that it was asymmetric I didn't notice a
lot of things when I was young but but
so it wasn't so hard doing you know
trying to do physics and because I
didn't take it very seriously because I
definitely want to be a physicist I
didn't have to worry about the fact that
other people didn't think I was very
good at it it didn't really matter to me
in fact what mattered to me was that I
was interested in it not that what
people thought of me amazingly enough
lately I worry about what people think
of me I don't know what happened I think
it could be the change the life change
but the kind of problems I had were ones
of being it was hard to focus it I
didn't have a lot of confidence and and
people were always trying to kiss you
and stuff like that like that you'd be
doing problems that's with somebody and
you'd be thinking about the physics and
they'd be thinking about your lips
alright you know you're whatever and and
that's complicated
so I actually I've been there a long
time I've been in Harvard for 22 years
and the thing I really like about the
physics department there is that
everybody is so confident and everybody
think it has such a high opinion of
themselves they don't really worry about
you know they're not threatened by me at
all except when I try it try and be
really threatening some of them who were
smaller than I am but but but that's
what that's one thing that I really like
about it you know and the other thing is
you know I was the first woman there and
they they had a little problem I mean
the first woman who had ten years so I
was the first woman who went to for
instance a senior faculty meeting of the
senior faculty and I remember after a
few faculty meetings professor came up
to me and said you know it might be a
little easier for everyone if you just
talked less because we're really not
used to having a woman at all in the
room and then one who talks so much is
it it's a little bit disconcerting so
that was interesting people people have
been generally pretty nice but you know
people in physics can be less evolved
socially than other people so you have
to deal with that